I am proud to be British, don't get me wrong.
I'm just not necessarily proud to admit that
I'm proud to be British.
I do definitely like to embrace my Britishness.
I know I fit a lot of the characteristics
of the British stereotype.
I sound a little bit posh, gray, rainy weather
makes me feel very at home,
I will genuinely say "whoopsy daisy"
when I've made a mistake,
I have an ever so slight disregard
for dental hygiene,
and maybe most importantly, I love tea.
It's kind of scary, actually, because I love tea so much
that it's become a defining characteristic of my personality.
Like I drink it everyday, it's the reason I earned
my first viral video when I was sixteen,
and now it's in the name of my
production company,
and yet the reason I love it so much is because
this is the island on which I happened to be born.
When my friend Michael came to visit
me from America,
I remember offering him a cup of tea because
that's what you do when you have a guest and
you're British, and he didn't really get it.
He said it tasted kind of hot, milky, leafy water.
He thought it was a bit yucky, basically.
And, honestly, I'm inclined to agree with him.
No baby in the history of Britain has ever popped
out of the womb gagging for a cup of tea,
but what we do is we see our
parents drinking it,
we hear that it's the British thing to do
and so we're slowly weaned onto it,
usually with lots and lots of sugar at the
start until we learn to love it.
And thanks to that process, tea is now a
part of who I am.
I need it to work, I need it to
procrastinate from working,
and thanks to my slowly formed caffeine
dependency, if I don't drink it, I get stroppy.
Like I drink tea because I don't
know what else to do,
but, for some reason, I still feel proud to be
a tea drinking British person.
Now whenever I see a patriotic American person,
you know, flying the stars and stripes
outside their home, singing the national anthem,
proclaiming about how much they love their country
and how it's the best country in the world,
it never fails to make me cringe.
And I think this is for a couple of reasons.
Firstly: I don't know if I particularly like the
idea of naming any country as being
the best country in the world unless
it can be completely objective.
And secondly: if we are going to name any
country as being the best country in the world,
I'd like to think we'd pick one with the humility
to not  go on and on about how great is.
But thirdly: big American patriotism makes
me feel weird because I am British.
Because the most patriotic thing you'll ever hear
a British person say isn't "God Save the Queen."
It's "Would you like a cup of tea?" or "Aren't we
having awful weather at the moment?"
I never chose to live here and yet,
for some reason,
I can't imagine myself ever wanting
to live anywhere else.
I never chose to have an accent that
sounds silly to the rest of the world
and yet, for some reason, that's not going
to stop me from using words like
"cheerio" and "poppycock" because I know those
sound silly to you and that makes me happy.
I guess what I have seen in a lifetime of
living here is that being patriotic
about Britain means not being particularly
patriotic about Britain.
Loving this country means admitting to yourself
and reminding the people around you that it can
be a bit rubbish here, and being proud
to be British means
being slightly ashamed of that fact.
And that is what I've been thinking
about this week.
Do let me know what you think,
and hopefully I'll see you next time.
God Save the Queen!
STEPHEN FRY VOICE: You've just had the almost
imponderable joy of watching charlieissocoollike,
which makes you, like, cool.
Thank you, as always, for watching.
You're very sweet.
Last week, I made three whole new videos.
It was a part collab week, all of which you
can see here in case you missed 'em.
My personal favorite is the one I wrote
with Tom where we wrote a song.
I know you're not really meant to pick favorites,
but I have now, so what am I gonna do?
It is my favorite.
That's just the way it is.
Enjoy whichever one you pick, though. Goodbye!
SILENCE